los ligamentos y los tendones son tipos
de estructuras densas y fuertes de
tejido conectivo los ligamentos conectan
hueso con hueso y los tendones conectan
el músculo con el hueso y al punto en el
que el hueso se articula o se encuentra
con otro hueso se le llama articulación
hay varios tipos de articulaciones y el
primer tipo de articulación se llama sin
artrosis y son articulaciones
inamovibles en donde dos huesos están
fusionados por ejemplo encontramos este
tipo de articulaciones en el cráneo los
cráneos de los bebés están formados de
varias piezas que crecen conforme crece
el cerebro y cuando se llega a adulto
estos huesos se fusionan y se vuelven
sin artrosis el siguiente tipo de
articulación se llama anfi artrosis y
anf y significa que ambos lados son
rígidos pero también ligeramente móviles
un ejemplo de anfi artrosis son las
articulaciones vertebrales y por último
tenemos las articulaciones y no viales
también conocidas como artrosis de las
cuales hay un par de tipos diferentes
uno de esos es el tipo rótula y hay
ejemplos de rótulas en los hombros y en
las caderas son articulaciones que
tienen varios grados de movimiento otro
tipo de articulación sinovial es el tipo
bisagra y unos ejemplos de la
articulación bisagra son el codo y la
rodilla en donde la articulación
básicamente se mueve en un plano como la
bisagra de una puerta las articulaciones
sinovial es se llaman así porque son
lubricadas por un fluido llamado fluido
sinovial que está contenido en una
cápsula sinovial que rodea a toda la
articulación las partes de los huesos
que se unen en una articulación están
forradas por un cartílago suave especial
llamado cartílago articular que está
formado específicamente por cartílago
hialino y el cartílago y ali no como
todos los cartílagos es vascular lo que
quiere decir que no tiene estructuras
vasculares o vasos sanguíneos por lo que
no le es fácil conseguir nutrientes para
sanar y recuperarse en caso de dañarse
por uso excesivo o infección
estén familiarizados con el hecho de que
el uso excesivo de las articulaciones
con el tiempo puede ocasionar
inflamación que se llama artritis de
'art que significa articulación en it is
que significa inflamación que puede
llevar a la destrucción permanente del
cartílago lo que ocasiona el dolor y la
rigidez de la artritis